-Hi, Annie. How are you?
-Hi, Seth.
I am doing just fine.
How are you doing?
-I'm doing well.
It's really nice to meet you
I wish it was in person.
But I was talking to your costar
Dan Levy,
and he was saying that, really
it's the most fitting outcom
that the year "Schitt's Creek"
gets 15 nominations,
it will be virtual Emmys
because we're in the middl
of a pandemic.
-Precisely.
I couldn't agree with him more
-[ Laughs ]
It must have been -- You know,
your show took this --
I feel like had this crazy -
"Arc" isn't even the right wor
because it just kept going up,
which is it was a show tha
not a lot of people saw,
and then there was this building
sort of cult feeling about it,
and then, all of a sudden,
in its final year,
it is an Emmy darling.
What a fun run that must hav
been for you.
-It's been so wild,
because when we started out,
it was really just this little
show on the CBC in Canada.
And we shot, you know,
in Toronto,
and then we'd go up north
45 minutes
and shoot in this little tow
called Goodwood, Ontario.
-That's hilarious.
-Hold on to that for a sec
So, yeah, it felt really small
and insular,
and so, to have it be wher
it is now is pretty wonderful.
-Is it true that
you felt nostalgic
and made a trip back
to Goodwood recently?
-Yep, yep.
It is not my finest moment
I would say.
I was getting a little
stir crazy and nostalgic,
and I was like,
"I'm gonna take a little drive
I'm gonna go to Goodwood."
And they have these --
There's a bakery in Goodwood
called Annina's,
which is the best bakery,
and they have --
Do you guys have butter tart
in America?
-No, I've never heard
of a butter tart.
-Okay, a butter tart
is just that --
a butter tart
but with brown sugar and -
Anyway, it's delicious.
So I said, "I'm gonna go get
a butter tart and walk around.
And so I did that,
and I was strolling around
the streets of Goodwood,
and this car of ladies
pulls up to me,
and they're like, "Alexis?
And I was like...
And I was like,
"What are you doing here?"
Like, because Goodwood, I guess,
has become a bit of a hot spot
for tourists now.
-Sure.
-But they had driven
three hours
to come and take pictures
in Goodwood,
and there I was just wandering
the streets like a maniac.
And then, literally
three days later,
the show "Schitt's Creek"
posted on socials,
"Please, people,
stop going to Goodwood.
There is a pandemic.
Everyone needs to calm" --
And I was like...
-[ Laughs ]
It is really funny because
of course, the last --
I mean, you might expect to see,
like, an Annie look-alike
that the town just hired
for the purposes of tourists
but to get the real thing
just wandering around...
-Now I think that they think
that I just go there every day
just to wait for people
to come and take my picture.
-To recognize you, sure.
This is something else that'
a little bit embarrassing,
but, again, this is somethin
that you made the mistake of
sharing with the world,
which is that when you found out
you were nominated
for an Emmy --
this is going around --
you choked on bacon.
Which is, by the way,
the way I want to imagine
all Canadian actors finding ou
about Emmy nominations,
is choking on bacon.
-It was one of those thing
that, like, as I was saying it
I was like, "Don't say thi
out loud to somebody."
But, yeah, I was sitting
on the floor eating pancakes
as one does,
and got the news
and inhaled or exhaled
in a poor way,
and, yeah,
that's how I rung in the news,
was choking on bacon.
-What -- I can't even imagin
what it was like
to have both comedy royalt
and Canadian royalty
in Eugene Levy
and Catherine O'Hara
as your parents.
What was it like when you firs
started working with them?
I mean, obviously,
the scripts are so funny,
but, you know,
they elevate it so much
by being the kind of performer
they were.
Was it intimidating, or was it
just amazing from the start?
-Both.
I'm gonna say both.
They have been my idols
for so many years,
and when I found out
I got the job --
Because I hadn't
worked for so long,
teemed with the fact that it
was my dream job that I booked
I was, like, floating
on this high
that I had a job
and I was gonna be working
with Eugene and Catherine.
But I didn't really realiz
until a couple of days befor
when a friend was like,
"Hey, you have to now act
with Eugene Levy
and Catherine O'Hara."
And I was like, "Oh, no.
Oh, no, no, no, no."
And it really dawned on me
and I had a bit of a momen
and was terrified going in
the first day.
I was so nervous.
But, luckily, Dan Levy
was equally green,
and he was nervous, too.
And so, we kind of went in
trembling together
and got the first few take
out of the way.
And then Eugene and Catherine,
being who they are,
it never felt like
we were the new,
inexperienced kids that we were.
It was so warm and awesome
and they couldn't have bee
more lovely, so...
-I was talking to Dan
about this.
You know, six years ago,
he and Eugene came on
to promote the premiere
of "Schitt's Creek,"
and, at the time,
I think the only thing anyon
knew about the show
was the choice that
they had made with the name.
And it was really fun.
One, they obviously --
You know, the secret's out
that they have a very loving
father/son relationship,
but you actually were
in the city doing press,
and I've heard that you
actually went --
you went to their hotel room
to watch it air,
which is probably
pretty late at night.
-I did, and it was.
I can stay up late.
Yeah, so that was one of
my very first -- of many -
but very first moments of
"what is my life right now?"
Because I was in New York City
for press,
and they put us up
at the Waldorf Hotel.
And we'd just gone out
for this beautiful steak dinner,
and there was a snowstorm,
and I was like --
I was crawling into bed,
and I got a call from Dan
being like,
"We're gonna watch
'Seth Meyers.' Come on up.
And gave me a room number.
And so, I pulled on
my rumpled clothes
and went up.
And it was, like, an
impressive number in the hotel
And so, I went up to the roo
and knocked on the door,
and Martin Short
dressed in a tuxedo
opens the door with champagn
and goes, "Annie Murphy."
And I was like, "What!?"
And so, I proceeded to go into
Martin Short's hotel room
at the Waldorf
and watch my friends
Eugene and Dan Levy
on "Seth Meyers,"
and it was a very, very --
I think it's like a
"flash before my eyes
while I'm dying" moment.
-It also seems very cool,
and I think one of
the most special things
about all the nominations
is that both Eugene and Da
got nominated,
and I can only imagine
how proud it made Eugene.
You know, he's got two kid
in the cast, as well.
Is it true that he just delights
in watching
his children perform?
-Couldn't be more delighte
watching his kids perform.
It is --
That is actually one of
the things that I'm gonna miss
the very most
about shooting,
is watching Eugene
watch Sarah and Dan.
Because he stands -- He goes -
First of all,
he goes and gets snacks,
and then he stands
behind the monitor
and just watches them act.
And he's much like a dance mom
or like a stage mother.
He mouths their lines and
is very sad when they're sad
and very happy
when they're happy.
And it's all of us.
Like, when it's going on,
all of the crew kind of
nudge each other,
and we all take great pleasure
in watching him watch them
-It is fully adorable.
And I want to ask
about Catherine.
She made so many
wonderful choices
in her delivery and diction.
Was there a certain word of hers
that you enjoyed
hearing the most
over the course
of the six seasons?
-Yeah, and it's not the word
you would expect
because it's not one of
the flowery,
you know, pieces of vocabulary
that she chooses.
But she was able to
make the word "how,"
just the word "how," just H-O-W,
three syllables.
So it went from how to "H-O-W.
-[ Laughs ]
-And it blew my mind.
It blew my mind.
She's a miracle.
-Yeah. Well,
you were very lucky.
To be that proximity
to greatness
is very rare in this game.
And it's really awesome
that the Emmy voters
recognized how,
across the board,
wonderful you all were
on that show.
And congratulations, Annie
-Thank you. Thanks, Seth.
It was really nice to meet you
-It was the same here.